tenéis un sobre en vuestras manos
con tres papelitos en el que habéis
puesto el nombre de tres personas
importantes en vuestras vidas
él había intercambiado con la persona de
al lado
ahora os voy a pedir que me dais la mano
en ese sobre y que cojáis al azar un
papelito
por favor mirar a nuestro compañero y
decirle el nombre de la persona que
aparece en ese papel
siento deciros que esa persona ha muerto
no vais a poder volver a verla ni a
tocarla ni a sentirla
no vais a poder volver a reírnos con
ella ni siquiera enfadados
porque ya no está
este ejercicio lo hacemos en cuidados
paliativos con las personas que quieren
dedicarse a estar al final de la vida
para que puedan sentir cómo puede ser el
perder a alguien
esto que acabáis de sentir incluso a lo
mejor algunos de vosotros ya lo habéis
vivido en vuestras vidas se puede hacer
caro para hacer lo que siente un padre y
una madre cuando van al hospital y le
dicen que ya no hay latidos
cuando se produce una pérdida prenatal
durante el embarazo la vida y la muerte
van juntas es una paradoja a la que no
estamos acostumbrados y en la cual es
muy difícil saber qué decir y qué hacer
en esos momentos
hace mucho tiempo ya viene una paciente
alicia estaba embarazada de su semana 40
era una mañana normal y corriente
desayuno y empezó a sentirse mal porque
no se nos daba el bebé algo estaba
pasando no sabía que pero empezó a
ponerse muy nerviosa rápidamente se
fueron para el hospital y al llegar a
urgencias le dijeron no hay latido y
ahora tenéis que quedaros porque tienes
que pararlo muerto
todo ese día que duró en el hospital fue
un día muy intenso en el que finalmente
se fue del hospital sin su bebé sin
tocarlo sin besarlo sin ningún recuerdo
ni siquiera le dijo lo que lo quería se
fueron con las manos vacías totalmente
su familia el tiempo que estuvieron allí
intentaron ayudarle intentaban animarlos
con determinadas frases posiblemente las
podéis reconocer mejor ahora que después
estará en el cielo la naturaleza muy
sabia
te saco las cosas de casa incluso ellos
fueron y le sacaron todas las cosas para
que a la vuelta no encontraran nada y
todo fuera más fácil conforme pasaron
los días la familia dejó de hablar de
ese niño e intentaron distraerlos todo
el tiempo y conforme pasaron los meses
era como si no hubiera existido nunca
ese niño
llevo 10 años en cuidados paliativos y
en duelo atendiendo a todo tipo de
duelos incluso en temas de situaciones
de emergencia el acompañar a las
personas en el dolor y en el sufrimiento
se ha convertido en algo muy importante
en mi vida profesional pero últimamente
el estar al lado de las personas cuando
pierden un bebé y de los profesionales
es algo muy importante porque no sabemos
cómo hacerlo
esto el duelo perinatal nos presenta dos
retos muy importantes uno a nivel
sanitario y otro a nivel social a nivel
sanitario
seguimos anclado en la idea de que la
muerte es el fracaso de la medicina y
esto nos lleva a que no tengamos
protocolos en los que se nos explica qué
vamos a hacer cuando esto ocurre a nivel
social seguimos pensando que hay que
quitar el sufrimiento de la vida
queremos dejarlo en los hospitales nos
vamos los rituales funerarios no
queremos a la gente que sufre no
hablamos de esas conversaciones hacemos
como si no existiera como si
desapareciera el dolor con ello
y a la misma vez esta situación nos
permite nos da la oportunidad del bolo
perinatal de producir cambio en la
sociedad y de hacernos preguntas
preguntas que quiero hacerme aquí con
vosotros para reflexionar
a nivel sanitario
creéis que sería necesario cuando un
papá y una mamá están embarazados
explicar las probabilidades que tienen
de perder un bebé habría que explicar
esto actualmente no existe un protocolo
en el cual explicamos esta circunstancia
nadie cuenta que va a ser después no
existen
deberíamos de visualizar a los niños que
nacen muertos deberían de estar en el
libro de familia pensáis que esto debe
ser así actualmente lo que existe es un
registro de legajos en el cual aparece
nada no aparece ni el nombre ni el
apellido de ese bebé
como llamamos a una persona que ha
perdido un hijo deberíamos de ponerle
nombre
cuando perdemos a nuestros padres somos
huérfanos cuando perdemos a nuestra
pareja somos viudos y cuando perdemos a
nuestros hijos le tenemos que poner
nombre
cuando algo no tiene nombre es muy
difícil visualizarlo es muy difícil
saber que existe
y nosotros los que estamos aquí
qué hacemos qué podemos hacer con los
demás con los de alrededor
[Música]
normalmente desde el cariño es la mala
intención intentamos cambiar a las
personas de alrededor intentamos que no
haya dolor lo intentamos distraer e
incluso hacemos y decimos estas frases
que le decían alicia no
es mejor ahora que más tarde ya tendréis
más si sois jóvenes el tiempo lo cura
todo os tenéis que distraer
hemos intentado entenderlo entendemos
las reacciones que tienen una madre
después de perder un bebé no puede ver a
un bebé pronto no es capaz de estar al
lado de una embarazada tiene mucho miedo
se sienten culpables para haber perdido
a su hijo todas estas cosas le ocurren
porque están viviendo el duelo están
intentando elaborar la pérdida de su
hijo y por muchos que tengan después
nadie va a sustituir a ese hijo y su
hijo ya ocupaba un lugar en su vida
como lo estamos haciendo deberíamos de
cambiar
todo esto nos lleva quizás hay algo más
grande a nivel social nos reconocemos
algo importante los bebés se mueren y no
lo aceptamos como sociedad y eso nos
está llevando a generar más dolor
qué solución podemos hacer todos estos
son retos que estamos intentando cambiar
os puedo contar lo que estamos haciendo
a día de hoy a nivel del hospital por
ejemplo estamos atendiendo a todos que
todos los padres y madres que están
viviendo una situación de duelo y que
necesitan intervención psicológica
hemos hecho lo que se llaman grupos
focales qué quiere decir hemos reunido a
padres y madres que han vivido esta
situación para que nos contarán cómo fue
su vivencia en el hospital para que nos
dijeran que necesitaban que cambiáramos
en el hospital y ha habido dos cosas muy
importantes que nos han trasladado una
de ellas necesitan tiempo en el hospital
también para sus decisiones
es importante ver a sus hijos tocarlos
despedirse darle cariño es muy
importante tener recuerdos de esos días
son los únicos recuerdos físicos que
tienen de su hijo y la otra parte muy
importante es que necesitan que tanto
ellos como su hijo sean tratados como
ser humano con dignidad y con respeto no
solo como un cuerpo
con todas estas cosas para hacerle
formar parte hemos empezado a realizar
protocolos de intervención
y además de eso hemos empezado a
planificar formación con el personal
sanitario todo esto forma parte de lo
que estamos llamando la humanización de
la salud
la sociedad que hacemos con la sociedad
que estamos haciendo
estamos visualizando el duelo perinatal
cada día aparece más información en las
redes sociales sobre testimonios sobre
libros sobre cuentos ideas sobre el tolo
perinatal de hecho este mes de octubre
el mes de octubre es el mes de recuerdo
para reconocer la pérdida casi en todas
las ciudades se van a hacer actos con
más negativos para recordar a todas esas
pérdidas que han existido no además a lo
largo de el tiempo se han ido creando
asociaciones sobre duelo perinatal y
grupos de ayuda entre padres y madres en
almería existe un grupo que se llama
alcora para que puedan ir las padres a
hablar y recibir ayuda
además hemos creado críticos para las
personas que están en duelo para que
entiendan las reacciones tanto ellos
como las personas de alrededor
hemos generado un cambio porque una
persona una paciente de duelo rígida que
perdió a su madre quiso ayudar y pintó a
mano esa habitación que antes estaba
vacía y era el lugar donde se informaba
a los padres quiso que hubiera una parte
de cariño de ella para esos momentos tan
delicados
estas cajas que veis un grupo de
adolescentes de cruz roja van a empezar
a hacerlas para que los padres puedan en
el hospital llevarse las y meter así
todos los recuerdos que tengan de su
hijo
y este grupo de jubiladas ha querido
colaborar con nosotros y han empezado a
tejer gorritos y patitos para que los
niños puedan ser presentados como niños
y no solamente como el cuerpo de un bebé
para que haya más dignidad
hace unas semanas como en otros momentos
del hospital nos volvimos a encontrar
con una de estas situaciones complicadas
familiares
antonio y maría volvían a estar
embarazados era su segundo bebé y era
muy buscado porque ya tenían una niña de
cinco años ella estaba tumbada en el
sofá con su hija cuando empezó a sentir
unos pinchazos era muy raro ella no
había tenido esas sensaciones en su
anterior brazo y estaba solo de 30
semanas así que rápidamente fue a dejar
a la niña en casa de una vecina y su
marido y ella se marcharon
fueron al hospital y al entrar por
urgencias le dijeron que mejor lo subí a
una planta para atenderlo y la
ginecóloga estuvo un rato con ella le
explicó que no había latido que lo
sentía que el bebé había muerto que lo
iban a acompañar en una habitación para
que estuvieran a solas con su familia y
explicarle todo el proceso que venía en
adelante
pude estar con ellos en estos momentos
pude estar con ellos para explicarles
que es todo lo que iba a ir ocurriendo
para saber cómo se encontraban cómo eran
sus emociones qué miedos tenían y
acompañarles sobre todo a decidir todo
lo que venía después que iba a ser muy
complicado decidieron en el parto
quedarse a solas con su bebé quisieron
cogerlo tocarlo besarlo le dijeron lo
que lo querían se despidieron de él e
incluso hicieron fotos está una de ellas
se quedaron con muchos recuerdos
incluso pudimos que los abuelos pasaron
a despedir a despedirse de ese bebé que
también era su familia
el día siguiente en el hospital
también pudimos trabajar con la familia
todas las cosas pendientes en el
hospital se le dio un gorrito se le puso
este gorrito que las enfermeras hacen
con todo el cariño a todos los bebés que
nacen incluso en un sobre meten un
certificado de nacimiento en el que se
pone la huella se le da la pulserita y
se le da todo aquello que haya para que
se puedan llevar los recuerdos
estuvimos con la familia trabajando
sobre todo qué iban a hacer después al
salir del hospital cómo acompañar cómo
trabajar con eso con esa niña que le era
su preocupación cómo decirle a la niña
que el hermanito había muerto que no lo
iba a conocer que físicamente no estaba
pero que iba a formar parte de su
familia toda la vida aunque estuviera
entrevista al principio lo iban a
recordar siempre porque era parte de su
familia
incluso pudimos trabajar con la familia
que acompañarán de otro modo que
pudieran aprender que estas frases sí
que ayudaban de verdad a ellos siento lo
que os ha pasado seguro que era un bebé
precioso
a quien se parecía siempre nos
acordaremos de vuestro hijo estoy aquí
para lo que necesitéis
pudimos hacer todo esto y ellos
decidieron irse a casa con su bebé
incinerarlo y posteriormente van a
decidir que hacían con las cenizas donde
querían esparcir las en un sitio bonito
que formará parte de su familia
dos semanas después llamamos a esta
familia para saber cómo se encontraba y
para resolver las dudas tanto médicas
como psicológicas sí que os puedo decir
que el inicio de la elaboración del
duelo está siendo normalizado por
supuesto con dolor porque la pérdida
supone un dolor pero nos dijeron que
tenían muchos recuerdos y muy buenos
momentos incluso de algo tan difícil
como fue estar en el hospital y además
que todo el personal lo habían tratado
con mucho cariño y eso era lo más
importante
bueno como resumen que aprendemos de la
pérdida de un bebé aprendemos cosas lo
primero que creo que aprendemos y más
importante es que todas las vidas
merecen el mismo respeto cuidado cariño
y amor con independencia de los días de
gestación o de vida que tengan
y lo segundo importante que creo que
aprendemos es que es importante hablar
del duelo perinatal reconocer el dolor y
el sufrimiento de las personas ayuda a
elaborar las perdidas
para finalizar quiero compartir con
vosotros la portada de este libro para
mí es muy especial porque el libro que
ha escrito una paciente de duelo ha
contado todo su proceso de embarazo
su tiempo en el hospital cómo fue la
vuelta a casa cómo fue su familia la
sociedad es una forma de ponerle
palabras a todo y de mostrarnos las
cosas bien hechas y las mal hechas
también y sobre todo fijaros en esa en
esa imagen esa huella que veis ahí en la
huella del pie de su bebé como un gesto
tan pequeñito en el hospital puede
transformarse en esa inmensidad de amor
para la familia
los padres y las madres que pierden
hijos son los que nos enseñan sobre la
vida y sobre la muerte
gracias
[Aplausos]